hello everyone i welcome you all to the
today's webinar
on chem informatics for biomedical drug
discovery program
today we would be talking about the
program in detail
and would meet our mentors for the
program as well so let us start with the
introduction about us
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who are working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators
to develop easy to use analytical tools
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
we are doing this by providing training
and tools that help people make
discoveries using next generation
sequencing
and other types of high throughput
sequence data
we see this as a result of accelerated
pace of biological data generation
and availability of next generation
sequencing technologies
throughout the different locations in
the world and widespread appreciation
of the accuracy and the details that
such data can provide us
my name is sunalika ray and i am the
omixlogic community manager responsible
for daily interaction with thousands of
users
that are a part of a bioinformatics
community
managed by pine biotech
our omics logic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech which
is an innovative big data analytics
company based in the us
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated
in content evaluation curriculum review
and project design
as a result the omixlogic program has
been thoroughly tested around the world
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes for students with minimal
bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical study
majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics data science and
biomedical research
i'm honored to have been working with
the team that collectively has amazing
experience in this area
including the other co-founders of the
company dr
alfred tauber who comes from a medical
background with expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information
he has a long-standing recognition for
his generous support of many
international
projects and research activities one of
these projects is the establishment of
the turbo bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
dr leonid brodsky is the director of
trouble bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications on
bioinformatics and over the course of
his career he has developed multiple
novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis
these have been widely used in basic and
translational research in biotechnology
pharmaceutical r d
agriculture and basic research our
platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people mentioned here on the
left
julia panna who is an expert
bioinformatician
and has helped prepare many of the
materials we will use
avitativsky who is a computer scientist
and leads the development of tbi info
platform that we would use
and i will be introducing our team
members in india in the next few slides
omex logic is an international program
that
is running in five different regions
with over 10
000 users around the world due to this
fast growth our team is working in
local and regional coordinators that are
helping refine
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
omixlogic programs follow project based
learning approach using research grade
tools to analyze data from top peer
reviewed journals
omics logic training has been completed
by over 10 000 participants
from 162 countries in over 300 workshops
for six different specialization tracks
being oncology
infectious diseases precision medicine
neuroscience data science for biomedical
data
and comprehensive training on omix data
analysis
to give a brief introduction of the
associations
fine biotech is a us-based company that
provides resources
solutions and training for research and
education and biomedical informatics
we have been developing an innovative
approach to incorporate bioinformatics
training educational materials
and biomedical specialization for
universities companies and top research
labs
faba academy is a special event under
the faba organization
that focuses on grooming the students of
the universities nationwide
and makes them future ready farmer
toppers a pioneering institute committed
to provide refined education to pharmacy
aspirants
and training programs in bioinformatics
for marker vigilance etc
probio technical research has a mission
to equip
and empower every student and faculty
with the latest technology
and tools to create an edge from others
i welcome all our collaborators here and
all of you
now i would like to pass it on to dr
suji to talk more about the program
over to you dr sujit thank you
thanks for introduction could you please
make me host
yes
you can now share your screen sir thank
you
please let me know if my screen is
visible to all of you
sonalika you can confirm yes it's
visible
thank you i again welcome all of you
for this webinar on chemo informatics
for biomedical drug discovery
so as you know we have already started a
four month intensive program of which we
have come
we have completed genomics model and our
transpo
transcriptomics model is going on and
from the 12th
of june we are starting a data science
program and again from
14th of june we are starting a drug
discovery program
so this data science and drug discovery
program is
uh will go up together i mean
one can in enroll for a data science and
a drug discovery
both the program or either of any any
available program
so for this four months intensive
industry oriented program we have
several partners as
uh sonalika said but yes for this drug
discovery program we have schrodinger
with us
who will help students to uh for various
drug discovery aspects
of all also molecular dynamics
molecular modeling techniques and
molecular docking
practical experience on all those
molecular docking and dynamic stuff
also schrodinger have committed to
provide around
four weeks of license for uh for for
training purpose those who have those
who are enrolling into this particular
program
so as uh so straddinger they are
actually
a software company uh
into a molecular modeling and drug
discovery space
so they are they are a computational
structure based screening and explicit
molecular dynamics they
will be working they are working on and
they'll deliver a talk
talk on the topics they would like to
cover are like
master gui gui
they will cover how we can uh sketch
organic
molecules how we can select a protein
how we can prepare a protein
how we can do screening of heat
identification of a molecule against
various therapeutic targets molecular
mechanics dynamics talking etc
so for this program we we have several
expertise uh
we have dr ajithi kamat from uh he's an
advisor at pandora technologies we have
chakra mesha who is a
ceo at made us bio and agent faculty as
you know
university of california we have dr uday
saxena
in next couple of minutes you would meet
him and
so he's a co-founder and region
co-founder of region biosciences and
he's a professor as well so we have dr
ramy reddy he's a founder and chief
scientific officer at national labs usa
and we have doctor punit kakar he's a
drug discovery scientist from accenture
uh we also have us uh team members from
schrodinger
pritish bhatt uh prajwal ajit abhinav
devraji kaushik and kishore from the
schrodinger team
so let us begin from a session so as i
mentioned
uh we are starting our session uh 14th
14th we have one more free webinar but
actual session is actually starting from
a 15th of june
so on a 15th or 15th of june you will
learn
about the basics of chemo informatics
what exactly chemo informatics how you
can use this chemo informatics in your
day to day life
and for your day to day research work so
we will uh
our expertise uh they will teach you how
the introduction of the kim informatics
what are the databases available
uh small molecule databases protein
databases
how we can calculate structural
properties of a molecule how we can draw
draw structural molecules uh what are
their uh
softwares available for drawing a
molecule and for visualization of a
small molecules and also
protein molecules and then we have
another session at 17th of june uh the
topic would be ai in molecular drug
discovery here
in this in this session you will learn
how what is the big data in the chemical
domain or in a chemo informatics domain
how we can how we can access that data
how we can
automate that data using a programming
let's say python programming
uh how we can represent those molecule
into different uh different structures
in a different way you you will learn
about it
uh we uh you'll also learn
overview of application of ai in
structure and drug
structure based drug design and
ligand-based drug design
and also will highlight some of the
virtual screening steps
what you can do for a virtual screening
we have another session that is a third
session on a 19th
june this could be a very intensive
session we will start this session from
a 10
10 am to evening 4 pm wherein entire
shortage
team would be available to guide you and
help you for your
all all your aspect in this in this
session
just a minute guys
yeah so uh as i said this is a
entire one day uh session entire day
session
uh so here you will learn many things
about structure-based drug designing
like uh you will get to know how master
works how uh master you
how you can use master gui how to
do ligand preparation and how to
calculate admi properties using mastro
or using schwadinger
uh you know to to start with a drug
discovery
or a drug development process the very
the very beginning point is you know
protein preparation
and uh if you need to find out a
molecular if you need to do
docking studies so definitely you have
to create a great generation so
the entire team will help you out to do
all these steps what are the parameters
which are essential for the protein
preparation
what are the uh what are the
care of what all other cares we need to
take care
while during protein preparation how to
analyze protein
whether we have to remove water
molecules or not whether we have to keep
us those integrated ions or not
everything everything will be guided by
our mentos and also we'll go ahead with
the molecular docking with the
schrodinger package or and also will
will have a session on analysis of those
talking results
so everything will be on a hands-on
session along
along with the practical and also will
have some theoretical sessions
and again on a 20th of june uh we have
this could be a fourth session for our
program and we have
morning 10 a.m to 4 p.m uh come
at the entire day program here uh the
participants will
uh our participants will learn about
molecular dynamics using basemont
uh the the topics which we cover are
like you know desmond introduction a
theoretical introduction of a desmond
then
we'll have a practical demo on a
molecular dynamics how we can perform
molecular dynamics for a
drug and protein and then we'll have
dismount trajectory visualization and
dismount molecular stimulation analysis
and also
organic molecules enumerations for the
entire day from morning 10 a.m to
evening 4 pm
uh on 22nd of june
uh as of as part of our fifth session
we'll again we'll jump into
uh several freely available software so
in the entire program we have made like
we will use schrodinger and also we'll
use several freely available softwares
to
to work on so in uh in the fifth session
we'll work on a molecular modeling steps
like we will work on
modulus space model for a homology model
built homology modeling and
other molecular modeling steps we'll
also do some gene or protein analysis
like binding site analysis prediction uh
those are
some modification of those genes and
gene sequence and protein sequences and
also we'll
learn something about cellular location
and disease health condition
we have a sixth session on 24th of june
wherein we'll explore several
databases uh could be a chemical
databases or a protein databases
so uh we we have several materials
too and we have several uh python
code to extract data from a pub game as
you know pubchem is the world's largest
collection of
freely available chemical information or
a small molecule information uh database
came spider is also another database for
small molecules and chembel is been
is also a small molecule database which
contains
curated molecules of bio curated biofuel
molecules along with a drug like
properties
so along with this databases you will
also learn
a pdb database other and other
gene and a protein sequence database as
well
as a part of six session as a part of
second
seventh session once we explore chemical
database and uh
protein database then we will we will do
again
practical hands-on docking using a auto
doc
out of vena so the entire session is
dedicated for a practical uh
docking a docking on a docking of a
small molecules to the
uh or to the large molecules and uh this
could be a flexible docking this could
be a rigid docking
and we will work on your problems as
well and also will
help you out how you can analyze those
docking results
and how you can you can take forward
those docking studies in your further
research
as part of session eight which we will
conduct on
first of july will the the topic would
be target identification
virtual training so we will you will
have an exposure to
the various methods for target
identification and validation and
will have some hands-on workshop on a
computer-aided virtual screening so this
question is being done by
chakra mesha and dr punet kakar
and then we'll have some advanced chemo
informatics topics and then again
also hands-on session uh for uh how you
can convert
heat to lead as you know entire drug
discovery process
so initially will will you will learn
how you can generate those leads and
then again
how you can convert those heat into lead
and again how we can
optimize those leads for further for
further our research process
so everything could be hands-on session
and uh we will mostly focus on freely
available tools so that you can use
those tools in your research work and
you can publish the paper
using those tools
and then again uh on 12th of july we
will have session from a schrodinger
and you will learn about free energy
perturbation what are those binding
energies what are those
bonds which are chemical bonds
physiological i mean uh ionic bond or
you learn about all those bonding
bond between two atoms and energy
between the
energy for those binding energy of those
binding uh
atoms and also we'll have some case
study uh on
industry application uh so we have focus
mostly on the part like the current
research is happening in an industry
so we will teach you or will guide you
what exactly industry is working on
and then uh we'll have a practical
session on a game suit game suit is a
chemo informatics package wherein if
someone doesn't have a knowledge of
machine learning or a chemo informatics
or a data science
still he can build machine learning
model or a deep learning model using a
game suit
so and uh he can do a lot of chemo
informatics stuff
like descriptor calculation data set
dividation
normalization of data and then analysis
and prediction of a newer data
so you will have you will you are you
actually you
you will get a chance to work a hands-on
session
on a game suit
uh again we will have on a 14th of july
we have a session
on a session by dr selu from ames
hyderabad
uh the and dr sailor will cover how we
can apply
our for our as in chemo informatics to
laura
the the entire session would be of again
practical session uh
so you will have uh so if you if you
don't know
r we will help you out uh to learn r and
you can do lot many things using our in
a chemo informatics space
and you can automate many of your steps
using our programming language
on 20th of july we have a session
by dr ajit v kamat from pandora
technologies uh he'll talk on
recent advances in a drug discovery what
exactly happening in this
drug discovery area and where industry
is looking for in the future you will
learn everything from him
on a 20th of july
uh on uh 22nd of july we have a talk on
talk by professor uday saxena he's the
co-founder of region biosciences
and he'll talk on a phase one to how we
can how the pharmaceutical company go
for
phase one to nda submission and he will
give a case study on example of
successful and failed
uh drug uh using a failed drugs for a
drug discovery or drug development
process
so so in the entire session you will
learn many things about drug discovery
from a
industry expert across the globe and uh
and also you will have a complete uh
theoretical along with the practical
sessions uh
from the from the experts of all all
those collaborators and
uh the the and this could be a the
entire one month could be a complete
knowledging
uh i would say uh complete knowledge
sessions for each and
one in our scientific community so with
this i would like to thank everyone
and now i'll pass it on to professor
uday saxena
uh to talk more on about this program
and about his experience
uh professor saxena over to you
sorry i i wasn't mute so that's sorry
all right so
thanks a lot uh can you hear me now yes
sir we can hear you
okay excellent so first of all welcome
everybody uh
i am very pleased to be here to talk
about this program and
i'll also specifically tell you about uh
you know the drug discovery and the
development
aspects that we will be talking about
from what i just heard from sujit this
seems like a very exciting program
from a person who is willing to learn
about the
nuances of drug discovery i see that
there's a beautiful blend of theoretical
as well as practical knowledge that you
will gain
so i really commend omix
for putting together such a beautiful
program
let me introduce uh myself first uh
so my name is uday saxena and uh as
sujeet said i am a co-founder of a
startup biotech company called
reagene biosciences
i have a phd and a post doc
like a lot of people who are in research
in
cell molecular biology and pharmacology
i started my career in a drug
industry in a company called park davis
pfizer in the u.s
and i was part of the team that
discovered a drug called lipitor
some of you might know it as an
atorvastatin
the brand name is lipitor this is a drug
that lowers uh
total body cholesterol and is used to
prevent heart diseases
uh the interesting thing about this
particular drug that i really
am excited to tell you about is the fact
that this was the
largest selling drug to date that has
been known
uh to humans so the peak sales of their
drug were between 17 to 20
billion dollars a year so it was really
uh
what in our industry we call a huge
blockbuster
from there on i went to do a startup
company in the u.s called
atherogenics where i was head of r d
and we took an idea all the way
into clinical trials i then became the
chief scientific
officer for dr reddy's which as you or
some of you may know is one of the
largest
indian pharma companies based out of
hyderabad
and after that i have become an
entrepreneur and uh doing
uh a startup company myself so
so that's about myself i am part of an
organization
called faba and faba is
a not-for-profit organization that
brings together um it's called the
federation of
asian biotechnology associations the
whole idea is to bring together
uh different biotechnology bodies from
uh india as well as enabling neighboring
asian countries
and share knowledge and faba academy
which is um actually a
it's it's something that has been um
launched by faba to educate young people
in the nuances of drug discovery so we
are currently in partnership with omics
right now and very excited to be able to
participate in this
let me tell you how drug discovery works
and also want to tell you what's the
benefit of some
for people like you to be going through
this course so
first of all i don't know how many of
you know this
drug discovery is an extremely long
process
it takes an average of 12 to 15 years
from having an
idea uh to all the way to bringing a
drug to the market
so it's a very long process the other
thing about
drug discovery is that uh it's very
expensive
the current estimates of bringing a new
drug to the market
uh is about a billion to two billion
dollars that's how much money
the company a pharma company has to
spend
before they can successfully launch a
drug on the market so
not only is it time consuming it's also
very expensive
process so why am i telling you this the
reason i'm telling you this
is the more knowledge we can have about
the idea that you want to launch a drug
on
the more likely it is that you're going
to be successful
most of the drugs are based around
protein targets and you will learn a lot
about protein targets in the program
that's been
put together and so it the idea would
start from saying
okay this is a protein that's involved
in say alzheimer's
and we need to block its activity say if
it's an enzyme
so up front you need to know everything
about that protein enzyme its crystal
structure it's
docking you know the whole nine yards so
the more
information you have about your target
protein
the more likely it is that you're going
to be successful
in using that to launch a product so the
reason i'm telling you and emphasizing
that
is this program appears to have all
elements that are needed to successfully
choose a target validate a target
understand how it works and then design
drugs around it so
this program really to to my knowledge
is one of the more extensive
programs i've seen that will educate you
on right from the beginning of drug
discovery which is
how do you choose a protein target right
so you'll learn that
once you learn that you have to design
drugs against it and you will also learn
some of that in this
suji talked about a hit to a lead so a
hit is nothing but your initial drug
candidates that you have
and then off the thousand that you may
have
you have to then whittle it down to
maybe five or ten molecules
that you choose forward so from a hit of
thousand you go to lead which is five
how do you do that there's actually a
very uh very well
thought out process that we go through
in the industry to do that
and in this program you're going to
learn about that as well
hit to lead and sujit has already talked
about that
then the drug moves into animal proof of
concept features you have to demonstrate
if it is alzheimer's you have to
recreate alzheimer's in an animal model
and show your lead candidates actually
provide any therapeutic benefits so
you'll learn some of that as well in
ajit commerce lecture
you learn about protein validation and
how drug discovery is taken from
selecting a target
all the way to establishing proof of
concept
the final and the most expensive part of
drug discovery it's what is known as
clinical trials
clinical trials are important because
the drugs we design
are eventually consumed by human beings
so there are two things that regulatory
bodies such as the united states food
and drug administration
wants from you if you are a pharma
company you have to demonstrate to them
that the drug that you have designed is
not only going to be therapeutic which
means it's efficacious
and protect against alzheimer's but it
also has to be
safe it's like a pilot right a pilot not
only has to
learn how to fly a plane but it has to
be done safely
the reason that is important is because
a lot of human lives are our state
similarly in the drug discovery and
development process
millions of human lives are at stake so
the us fda
and other regulatory bodies in the world
want to make sure that the drug that you
want approved
and launched in the market is safe
in order to demonstrate that you have to
take it through
clinical trials and the clinical trials
typically start
in what is known as phase one clinical
trials
where you do some healthy volunteers and
demonstrate that it is safe
then you move into a small alzheimer's
population
maybe 500 alzheimer's population
and show that it is efficacious and then
you have to move it into like a 5 000
alzheimer's patients that is called
phase 3
to show that it is not just safe but
also active in a larger population
so this is what is known as taking a
phase
one all the way through an nda once you
complete
all this you assimilate all that
information
into a document called new drug
application or nda
you submit that to the fda the fda will
probably take six months to a year
to very carefully review it and then
say yes the drug is approved or not
that's really the end
so you will also and i will be talking
to you about that and i will also not
just talk about how to do a phase one
phase two phase three
but how do you successfully design a
clinical trial right
because clinical trials alone take about
70 percent of the
budget so if you're going to spend half
a billion dollars
clinical trials probably will take up
two to three hundred million dollars of
that
so the whole idea is not to fail in a
clinical trial
all of the failures if you want to have
any should happen
in the beginning part and that's what
you will learn how do you select a
target
how do you validate it how do you design
a drug it
is okay to fail at that stage because
it's not very expensive
but as a company we do not like to
fail in a later stages because it's so
much more expensive
right so i will tell you how certain
drugs were
successfully designed for example i will
tell you about a torostatin lipitor
it was actually the seventh product in
its class
being launched and yet it became the
front runner
why was that what was it about that drug
that made it competitively beat out six
other similar drugs
and went ahead what was the strategy
what was the rationale
what was the clinical trial it's very
important that the clinical trial has to
be designed
from a market perspective also it's it's
not just enough to be able to
demonstrate that your drug is safe and
active
but you also have to convince a
physician
to prescribe it you know the physician
will want to know
why should i prescribe your drug versus
the three other drug that's already
there
right and that's all science driven
that's the science that goes behind the
commercialization so
i will spend a lot of time behind how
successful drugs were designed
and i will also showcase for you how a
bad clinical trial design and i've gone
through that also not only have i gone
through a successful drug design
but in the startup company that i went
to after park davis
we actually had a drug fail in phase
three after spending 800 million dollars
so what went wrong what were the lessons
so i'll tell you about that
as well so i think in summary what i'm
trying to tell you is that this is a
very exciting course for anybody who
wants to be educated
in this whole business of translational
research
slash drug discovery and as somebody who
has run
large organizations such as dr reddy's
i'll tell you one of the things i looked
for when i was hiring people was
what knowledge do they have of the drug
discovery business that they get into
right
so more likely i always like to hire
people
that had more knowledge about what they
were getting into than
people who had no knowledge at all so
some of you may be interested in a
career
in the industry so this course will
educate you
in what it takes to get to the industry
so
i'm very excited to be part of this
program
and really look forward to meeting all
of you
uh i believe my session is on the 22nd
of july
but you will also hear from some of my
colleagues sujeet manson
ajith kamat ajit is also an industry
veteran he has worked at pfizer
and he's going to tell you about the
early phase you know how do you select a
drug and all that
so both parts are very important what's
called
the preclinical part that ajit is going
to address
and the clinical part which is what i'm
going to address so
i think i'm going to stop now but thank
you very much for your time
and i hope to and i hope and look
forward to seeing you
at these workshops
thank you sujit i'd like to turn it back
to you now
thank you sir thanks for nice uh talk
and nice uh highlighting
about the program uh i would like
sonalika to take over from here
thank you so much dr sujithan thank you
so much dr uday saksana for sharing your
experience with us and letting know the
importance of this program
now i would want to invite dr mohit to
talk more about the program over to you
dr mohit
okay thank you sunanika
hello everyone as you know
as you have discussed as we all have
discussed and uh
okay so is my screen visible scenario
yes it's visible
just a second i'm having some i'll just
share again
yeah uh so as well as i was saying that
we
learned today a lot uh about
the application of uh structure the
application of gaming informatics for
biomedical drug discovery
so in this entire program uh we will be
going and
learning about different aspects of
biomedical drug discovery
so we started with genomics and we
wanted to learn about the sequences and
the differences in the context of a
disease
and then we learned about the gene
expression in the transcriptomics
program
and also now we are learning going to
learn about the application of data
science
and how we are using data science in
this entire
process of biomedical drug discovery and
uh alongside uh with the data science
and all of that
sequence based knowledge now we are
transitioning into the structural
space so it's very exciting to be able
to do this with all of you here who
would be joining us for this entire
entire course this will be a intensive
one-month course
where you will have like regular
sessions uh to discuss
and where we will be going through the
topics that you saw
that's what dr sujeeth showed you that
will be covered
during this period and also
uh the purpose of doing this
omix logic training programs is to help
you
and guide you develop these uh
learn from these techniques and develop
uh research
research ideas research projects so
one of the purpose would be to learn
from the very basics so that's why there
is two there are two phases in this
program
the first phase focuses on the
technology and the techniques
that are very much uh used in today's
biomedical drug discovery uh pipelines
so
i think many of you have heard about
protein structures
and with uh the sas growth ii the
variants
and how the variants change the
structure the function and all of that
so i think we will be covering a lot of
those basic concepts of how do you
understand how do you visualize
how can you look at the structure so
that's very important
because in the end what we are trying to
find is we are trying to find different
strategies
to be able to understand and devise
using these different tools
but again uh we will have to go back to
the very basics of understanding these
three structures
in quite detail so that we can apply
these different techniques like
uh like qsr or docking or molecular
dynamics
so in this program we will be covering
um
some of these techniques which will be
used in the context of a disease
so if you are already working and if you
are a full
uh program participant then we will be
working
in for a project that could be applied
for these different diseases
if you already are working on a project
so many of you are researchers here
and are working on different sort of
research topics or labs where you are
working on different projects that are
related
uh somehow related to bio biological
research
so in that case if you're working on
structural data if you're working on
sequence data if you're working on a
protein
if you're working on some drug discovery
aspect then it's a program for you to
join
because in this program you can uh
reach out to us we will be there to
guide all of the students who would be
joining to devise
the strategies and what what are the
strategies that you can take forward to
you know
to help your research go to the next
level
so if you are working on some hypothesis
you have some goals
some research objectives that you have
defined in your thesis maybe that you
have defined in your
in in the next uh few days that you will
be covering
so all of those will be there uh
we'll be helping you with that so as i
was telling you the next session
would be by uh will be a free session
uh which will be an intensive session
because it's going to start
uh at 6 00 pm first we'll have the
strategier
strategy workshop for one hour where you
will get an overview of the entire
software and what are the different
applications
so as i was telling you that omix logic
learning helps in
just not about learning it's about
application
and learning the logic so we will be
using
two propriety softwares here one is the
t by info platform for
most of our analysis that we did in
genome for genomics transcriptomics
data science and also there are aspects
of data science and chemical space
uh structures uh two dimensional or
three-dimensional structures and
molecules
that will be used for machine learning
but other than that
uh we will be using two propriety uh
software's
uh one is the t-bind for platform and
also the schrodinger platform
but the logic of the analysis would be
same for
every kind of research that you will be
doing so you can apply
uh those techniques and use open source
softwares in the next stage where you
are
trying to do your own research and you
not to be dependent on it
but to be learning the logic and how to
apply these techniques
and get an outcome or a result that
actually relates to the biology of the
problem so
how close you are to the uh to the
problem of mimicking this
uh in biomedical drug discovery so we
will be doing
docking simulations so we will be doing
learning about molecular dynamics
stimulation so what we are doing in this
in those simulations is to try to mimic
uh the stages uh where we can try to see
that how the molecule fits
if it is stable or not what would be the
free energy
so all of those will be covered uh
in the program in the context of the
program when we will be having the
workshops and then we will have the
understanding of how computer drug
discovery
is useful in this entire process of
biomedical drug discovery
uh so we have another session after that
on first july by dr chakra mesha and
you've already heard about
it like it would be about target
identification and validation
so how do we identify targets at the
beginning
of the experiment and if you already
have a target
then how do you validate that to be a
good target whether
if you if you find uh if you're looking
for a solution
for example if you're looking at a
disease if you're looking at
i want to work on a specific uh disease
so we have different
examples here um in our omics logic
training
where we go we have gone through
infectious diseases so we have gone
through examples of coping 19
malaria and tuberculosis
all of those examples to learn from and
then we have
examples in cancer research where
biomedical data drug discovery
and machine learning and using uh
patient
information all of that is is as much
as much used and there's a huge
application
so understanding that in the context and
how to apply
this in using uh programming languages
such as
or statistical languages such as r so
there will be another expert session by
dr shellu
from ames on 14th july that would be
about game informatics using r
and then as you already have seen that
understanding the
recent advances in drug discovery
so as i was telling you that machine
learning
first we learned about these techniques
then we discussed about
uh the way it is being used in drug
discovery
but in kami informatics like um i think
artificial intelligence has
inspired computational uh this
computational area drug discovery
and this widespread adaptation of
machine learning in particularly
uh you have heard about deep learning
you have heard about
uh the google platform uh that came up
to predict
uh protein structures so
understanding the way uh modern drug
discovery is working how artificial
intelligence
is uh you know enabling uh this
entire process of drug discovery and
it's fueling the development right
so there has been a kind of skepticism
before when we started with all of this
but this growing data and the
continuously
continuous development of these
resources have uh
really led to this entire process to be
really much more defined and now
we are believing in it and we are seeing
some results so
uh like this benefit comes from
medicinal chemistry comes from
ai comes from all of those allied fields
radiology and we are using patient data
so emr records and all of that so
understanding drug discovery
in this in this entire intensive program
would be about multi-disciplinary
aspects of drug discovery so it will not
be just about
finding a molecule and docking and just
finding the structure but to understand
in our
aspect in the aspects of the disease
and if there are resistance how to
overcome that
if there is a problem of drug
repurposing
how to look at that and how to
incorporate multi-omics data as well as
gaming informatics information into a
project so these are some of the
objectives that we have
that we have started with and uh and i
believe that we will be
able to complete some of these analysis
during this program and help you all
to learn from what we have gone through
in our entire career
what we have learned from all the
experts and
we have an a group of experts from
a lot of experience from what they have
gone through in their own ex journey in
pharma
so i'm really excited to be a part of
this program and become
and be a mentor to many of you who would
be working with us
on these different aspects now i'd like
to
hand it over to sunalika to tell you
about the registration process
and how you con how how can you come on
board
and start working with us thank you
thank you so much dr mohamed
okay so those who have already
registered
they would get a mail of how to proceed
further
and those who have not yet registered i
request them to
please hover on this page i would be
just sharing the link with you
and please register yourself
now how do you register you need to go
to the request mode information tab
and then you would be directed to join
the webinar to learn more and a
registration form would pop up which you
can fill easily
and we'll get your registration and
we'll get back to you
we have all the session details on the
program page as well
so those who get enrolled with us for
the program
they would get all these session details
and also the recordings of each and
every session on the program page
and also you can learn more about the
session
topics on this page and to see the
pricing as we are getting a lot of
questions on pricing the pricing we have
divided it
into three parts that is beginner
intermediate advanced
now this uh division of uh pricing is
just based on the provisions which would
be given to you these provisions are
mentioned here
and uh we also wanted to tell you one
thing
that for those people who can't afford
to
pay for the program fee like we were
getting a lot many requests
they can fill up the scholarship form
we'll go through your
application and then we would get back
to you
with what percent off we can provide you
for the program
and also we have discounts for group
registrations
as well so those who come up in groups
would definitely get the benefit
while enrollment for the program
and now if anyone has any doubts they
can
ask i hope i open the stage for the
questions now
and those who were asking about the
certification you would definitely get
the certification
once you complete all the assignments
which would be given to you
throughout the program course and you
would also get the mentorship that is
you
all your doubts would be clear then and
there in the session and if it's
not possible to be clear there you can
reach out to the mentor later and clear
your doubts as well
so i would be sharing the details all
the details in the chat box
and those who want to reach out to me to
ha uh
clear any doubts you can mail me at
marketing at the rate
pine out bio or you can also mail doctor
move it at
moment at the rate pine dot bio
we would be looking ahead towards your
participation
and we are waiting to hear from you
thank you so much everyone for joining
today i can see ajay has raised his hand
yes aj
please yes ma'am you can argue to
yourself and ask your question
am i audible uh sorry aj you're not
audible can you please
raise your volume actually
[Music]
already unmute any hair right now
uh yes yeah man yes sir
uh sir actually i'm currently jrf
in csr lab hello
yeah yeah please go ahead okay so
do we require any nfc for the this
program or not
uh i don't think you would require any
um
my supervisor how can i join this
program
because there are some works in lab
so it is also essential to
submit all the acknowledgement to my
guide or supervisor
for the purpose right
so if you have a format for no objection
certificate you can send us
send this out to us and then we can
review and then we can get back to you
okay and actually because of that
as you say that previously some
bioinformatics program was also
conducted
but because of this problem i could not
register there yeah so we can also like
schedule a meeting with your faculty or
your guide to let them know about what
this program will be and how this will
be conducted though
in the sessions are scheduled at an
evening time so we will be
having the sessions at 7 00 pm 5 pm 6
p.m mostly
the sessions are at 7 00 pm and they
will be for
uh 60 minutes 90 minutes and then uh you
will get an
opportunity to do this hands-on using
the cloud platform
so i think many of these this can be
done by your own
and you can also watch the video
recording that we'll be sharing just
after the session
so uh i think you can be you can be
doing this
on your own without you know all of that
uh
time commitment that you have so you can
it could be that way as well
sorry to interrupt but previously i have
took some
uh five days uh by some classes of
informatics
even i did chemo informatics through
some other
institutes but i could not get that much
you know
space for myself as i i was not in
the field but i could not get that much
expertise in that
i have started myself i did that and
i'm not blaming on that institution but
it is my lack
that i could not perform better there
well that i don't know about but i'm
what i can tell you is that that
five days uh km informatics
is a daunting task so you get to learn
about uh application how to use
the software or how where this applies
to but to be able
to work or to actually get good at
something i think
uh i mean more experience is required
and this is like
more than a month course and it's just
not about this we also have a
bioinformatics community
so where you can ask your questions
where there are like this community you
will be getting
access to once you join us or once you
join the learn platform
so uh i think it would not be just about
that it
is also about communication and how you
interact with
the peer peers that are there and learn
from them
and we would encourage you to do all of
that in this program
so it wouldn't it would not be only
about you know
just going through this modules and
going through the sessions you will get
a
mental guidance in the sense that you
ask us questions we reply you there we
give you
uh guidance for what to do next because
we also have a slack channel
where we will be adding the program
participants it's a direct channel with
all of the mentors so this is like
direct communication
with all all of them so it gives you a
lot of you know
um a lot of opportunities uh i mean to
easily
get get things done and go to the next
step in your learning
and at the same time i think many of the
participants
who have not done well with us also it's
because of the time issue
obviously they were not able to give
enough enough time
but i think if you can you know
figure out that how you can uh if it if
the
sessions are pre-scheduled so you can
figure out based on that your own
schedule
and then it would be easier for you i
guess
all right thank you sir yeah no problem
thank you so much yeah if anyone else
have any questions please
you can mute yourself and ask us
i am sharing the link of the social
groups we have
so uh if you want to stay updated with
all the programs we have in future
you can follow us there
i think that was it and if you uh want
to ask out something then i'll share the
mail ids as well you can email us and
we'll get back to you
thank you so much everyone for joining
the webinar we look forward to hearing
from you thank you so much
i said